oh [__] you bad [__]
you
BAM you bad [__] uncle Joey
here another fun-filled evening we're
going deep tonight into the Metis fear
of death I can't do no stars because the
anesthesia tomorrow your flashbacks we
got that's what the lady told me oh you
don't confess look at this [__]
reefer right here look at this now when
you guys go to New York people always
tell you in New York with your Cali with
your Canadian wheat this is [__]
calorie right here take a look at this
[__] meteor of death right here you
see that right there let me see that
you take this up your [__] ass with a
baster
you'll be hot for 32 days straight don't
worry about how much of this don't be
asking questions check it out [__]
I'm not even gonna smoke this I'm saving
this for the [__] after surgery I'm
just gonna look at it every day like a
[__] periscope there but never fear
uncle Joey's here we got a little [__]
King Louie the [__] third we got
little blue cookies that's tremendous
and a bung right here the bond of debt
will fill up you've got to be crazy you
gotta have a real name
there we go [__] it's Sunday
night but don't worry about nothing you
know me dog I did a couple
pharmaceuticals tonight I picked up all
my [__]
hey go Lisa I'm gonna take you somewhere
you gotta be on tip-top alert if I'm
down you're 125 250 375 500 625 750
that's why it took a dealer I didn't
even count that [__] I just took out a
SLIC 750 from cuz as we always say
please in training a beautiful
[__] day to be alive
you know arse dog always trying to put
the pieces together so that when they
turn that back on you you have the
chance to pull up nice and what are you
[__] nuts or what we're gonna want
deep tonight
[Music]
it's Sunday night I haven't seen you
[__] tomorrow
there's the pre-surgery Church what's up
dog oh [__] we're gonna pack this
[__] and show you how it's done
but you [__] it's still a
little confused what would have fun
flavors and what he brings to the table
you know I'm saying listen guys I get
the weed to [__] print smoke there
itself is the [__] principle
you
all alone dying of cancer are you
[__] nuts
there you go [__] get your [__]
together smoke them if you got them if
you're not turn the [__] periscope
off and go to an AEA meeting go hang out
with those people drink coffee whatever
the [__] it is that you do young sam
[Music]
nunn my smoke a little weed with family
on a Sunday night post UFC pre EBI
leaves over there gonna enjoy it where's
my [__] bottle when do I get a taste
of the anger I'm gonna for a special one
for you there's the anthem [__]
if you don't know now you know
you
[Music]
I just lost $50 in [__] when I trade
it back in they got a smell that [__]
gonna say it's a Jew for make more for
the soldier one more [__] LBGT
community unclear hit that [__]
wait we all get a small sum same he's a
[__] soldier people please come a
long way don't [__] ok here we go here
we go cops
[Music]
you
that's it when you lose control you'll
reap the harvest you have some you some
saying you don't even [__] can you man
you an acid you do that
[Music]
Galvis for this [__] when you're high
that's the whole [__] thing so you
know where the [__] you slipping you
need one more bomb there you over there
we're ready to shoot this [__] little
foot you don't bunk it's at home if
you're under 18 hang up now if not it's
bong hits for [__] life here you
understand me if not go hang out with
your buddies it's the Lord's Day you're
not kind of smoking G weed for Jesus
what's your purpose
whether you're Baptist Christian Jesus
is the man right so what the [__] is
sitting there with a finger up your ass
looking at me like on the back I'm just
helping you up listen the Bible
different [__]
[Music]
you're sitting there go enjoy what the
[__] you talking about Pink Floyd
animals you know I had to do like 50
it's acid you salmaah know respect gotta
work yourself up the ladder I listen to
leave do it because I got a fast phone
let's go we hit that [__] bong hardly
[Music]
playing the tuba
take the bar don't drop the funk you're
in training we know don't start the
daily value if you're a training you're
[__] training you understand I don't
want to hear no [__] stories nothing
leave that door open leaves a soldier
soldier he's gonna pee battling the
bottle that this thing will [__] kick
you like [__] getting to none you did
it correctly good googly moogly
[__]
either you're gonna [__] and do this
I'll go do homework or something oh wait
a t-shirt or something like that
yeah you guys like read oh my god yeah
it's such a great t-shirt go [__]
yourself get it together
I got a hydrate for the anesthesia
tomorrow they're gonna [__] break
this bugle off I'm getting sick just
[__] thinking about it guys I had
nausea all afternoon and nausea me taja
I went to jiu-jitsu tried to get rid of
it I got rid of it for a while oh then I
couldn't take aspirin after jiu-jitsu so
I feel everything of my 53 you're all
[__] body you know how these guys
some day you'll be [__] 53 and you'll
think of me right now you're young
you're at home you're whacking off eight
times you go drinking it's not blow you
sleep two hours the [__] catches up yeah
I never thought that my [__] nose
would be [__] up what'd you expect I'm
only seven years of doing that [__] plus
God knows what else
God knows that they're gonna find I got
a thing that's been growing inside my
nose here for years not even [__] with
it every once a while squeezing the
skinny slack comes out and when I pull
that and it's like six inches tremendous
I eat it you know me I'm a [__]
[Music]
sometimes listen I'm so used to eating
Coast nuts
I eat everything now whatever comes out
of my nose lint sometimes they get a
piece of lint through the sleep apnea
machine you feel it going in there all
night lifting like that like a bug you
ready for another bun oh my god this
King [__] Louie is the real deal
Holyfield my whole [__] he is
the red they hurtin shoot oh [__] yeah
people listen I've told you once I told
you a thousand times I [__] do a lot
of [__] up [__] when it comes to weed
it's my [__] life you know it's my
[__] life I love it I know I'm gonna
lose audio middle you know what I smoked
a little puta Luke I don't bother no
blasts and I write those [__] stupid
things I say on stage called jokes then
I'm a little bit confused it's fine for
another part are you ready are you gonna
[__] sit there
let's read hi times go [__] yourself
ain't no [__] High Times in my world
we get high Louie what's happening
that's your new name little Louie the
third Lisa asked my little brother don't
be [__] this guy he made his [__]
bones you understand you should have
seen him he killed his triple one night
he's buried in German what [__] lie
on him he's a [__] Louie the lineman
deaf dumb and blind you just keep on
pretending everyone's expendable it is a
creepy [__] place
Tanya this body's up the milk
and if you walk in those weeds off to
170 you'll find a key local or $22,000
I know so I know so for a fact that's a
that's a creepy road there somebody gets
off Sherman Way or the one after wood
cops are chasing they throw that shitty
for weeds they go back to the next day
they can't walk around it the capsule
watch it trust me you walk around the
170 you will find the bag of money
I hate true dump you don't be I don't
walk [__] I walk from the other
extreme sometimes for the wire that's it
I don't want to walk around the weeds
and mosquitoes they bite my little white
legs they should German smart that
[__] soldier Oh
[Music]
david gilmour
his [__] totally brilliant on the
south he's great on the wall he's great
on metals he's great on thought side of
the bowl but this he's great and wish
you were here
he goalie killed his soldier it's a
little baby I already started what do
you look like me always go below the top
just to [__] Dave Gilbert he has a
spa he's drunk done on that
motherfucker's is 215 what time is it 7
[Music]
[Applause]
then a camera in your lawn I wanna make
this go down who was told what to do by
the man
[Music]
Sunday night god bless you I hope you
have another [__] great week you know
you had a bad week last week it's behind
you [__] this week is what listen if
you [__] really think I want to walk
around with straws in my [__] nose
for a week I'm walking into a week a
hell you know what I do it I get it over
with I breathe better
maybe I'll exhaust this [__] fat to
burn little better who the [__] knows
me out of them
I'm petrified I analyze
you know there's some people to take
their arm stitch it up like Rambo
I can't imagine waking up tomorrow and I
can only breathe out of my [__] mouth
it's a it's a nightmare you understand
me but I gotta do it
you know and if I have surgery I can't
go back these two combines feel so it's
a catch-22 you don't say I don't dig
those guys don't like them at all I
don't wanna go there bingo in this guys
funeral I gotta go I'm saying like now I
feel like that I made a few calls people
like that us whether I talk to Frankie
impede me like it's gonna be quick one
day but I still feel like dick so what
are you gonna [__] do young saying
let's do a bong it whoa what's with the
[__] chitchat let's do a [__] bong
hit right and we'll make this right
that's how we roll and he probably
showing up with those psyches he wants
the Indian to come out it can't happen
it can't happen here
[__] rainbow 82 can't happen here
let's do this bond him then we'll get
this party started
what have you done all day I've been
doing [__] stretching my diaphragm oh
yeah you gotta get the party started
give you a bong for Christmas let you do
five bunk it's a date for you put snow
in there ice whatever how are you tired
you beautiful people I'm on Sunday
nights I used to watch Disney with your
family from 6 to 7 or [__] mutual our
maja if you were really lucky really a
Gentile they made you watch [__]
Lawrence what I used to watch Lawrence
Walker I was a Spanish kid I didn't know
what the [__] they were saying but they
were dancin around I don't see it on but
uh look what you got on a Sunday nice
huh
you got some [__] fat [__] talking to
you smoking pot where you get your fuel
duck for a [__] week [__]
Churchill what's happening now give me
about ten minutes I'm gonna get this
party started I'm happy your
[__] came by and hung out and
party a little bit I was feeling a
little down you guys made my [__]
night I love you [__] Eddie say
aloha I love you too that's my dog right
there I'll see you guys in about ten get
your lives together stay black uncle
Joey loves you if not have a great
[__] week around
to [__] today watch [__] nobody wants
to be around stinking people